eh bien nous voici de retour à aja 2016
en quasi direct de la remise des prix
puisqu'on reçoit évidemment la
championne de france 2016 sophie les
beaux jours sont finis
bonjour specta l eau que ça fait plaisir
la cinquième titre à son palmarès
oui c'est et c'était très dur très très
stressant à les parties de départager
chez vraiment très contente organise
cette année alors on a des petits objets
à côté de nous parce que évidemment ça
c'est les trophées un corner des
champions on est les champions aussi
d'ailleurs puisque mathieu cornette
aussi a reçu en tant que champion de
france comme toi championne de france ce
fameux petit vase dans lequel ceux-ci
que ce vase parce que il a l'air de rien
en fait il a une tradition en france
c'est pour s dessaivre voilà offert par
le président de la république qui a été
confectionnée dans la manufacture de
sèvres
et ouais pour garder un truc bien
français il est beau ce vase
regardez-moi ça et donc ça fait on 5e
oui qu'est ce que parce qu'on met dedans
havas rien c'est d'avoir en tout voilà
c'est un objet collection un trophée
super trophée et puis évidemment des
fleurs à ses jocelyne wolfango qui offre
aussi les fleurs qui s'occupait il y
aura très attentionné avec réfléchi que
tu connais bien puisque tu as aussi
gagné des titres de champion de france
rapide aussi qu'elle organise donc amusé
à 00h08 alors racontez nous ce tournoi
parce qu'évidemment savoir qu'est ce que
ça fait comment commence à se comment ça
se déroule un tournoi comme ça en gros
est ce qu est ce qu il ya eu des phases
importantes e vois ça j'ai assez bien
j'avais assez bien commencé j'étais
assez contente de mon temps moi j'étais
à 5 sur 6
j'avais à ce moment là je crois j'avais
un point d'avancé et france était très
bien parti et trois dernières parties
très décevant
j'ai fait trois nuls et ça que j'étais
avec dans ma position parfois un peu
difficile d'avaler que tu sers le lis
parce que le niveau de jeu et tu étais
pas très bon même si je mens général
j'étais assez satisfait de ma position
après l'ouverture et puis et puis je
lâchais ça se retournait et puis
finalement j'ai déjà réussi à sauver
quelques-unes s'est lancée un peu la
fatigue fait pour moi aussi peut-être
géré la fin de soissons tout le monde
est fatigué ouais ça et c'est très très
dur très éprouvant comme tournoi parce
que non seulement il ya les parties non
plus à la préparation pour les parties
moi je me prépare beaucoup assidûment me
trompe par est de 3 heures en général le
matin donc c'est donc c'est vrai qu'à la
fin il n'y a pas de journée de repos
puisque le vendredi soir et la
simultanée que j'ai joué oui alors ça
oui ça peut peut-être pas aidé ça parce
que tu as joué la nuit des échecs
alors on peut noter quand même ça parce
que bon c'était un moment d'agen 2016
s'est tenu des échecs c'est à dire que
vous avez joué à quatre il y avait aussi
laurent frayssinet adrien demuth et
tigran gharamian donc et toi vous été le
cas de champion vous avez joué quasiment
chacun environ 24 parties en deux fois
12 en fait on peut peut-être même un peu
plus donc c'est une centaine de partis à
quatre et tu étais pas loin
en plus de réussir un extraordinaire
100% quand j'étais un peu tellement on
était un peu super étonné parce que les
autres grands maîtres avait lâché des
nuls même des pertes et toi tu es
de tout finir et c'est juste à la fin
que tu as là chez eux
oui gvt âgées personnes particulièrement
juste à la fin c'est vrai que j'ai tout
gagné sinon je sais pas à chaque fois
que je joue j'ai envie de gagner alors
peut-être les autres le prenais un peu
moi je prenais un peu plus relax je sais
pas mais bon avec leurs résultats
étaient prêts vont y avait aussi il faut
dire des bons jours cette année avec un
bon niveau et évidemment ils ont eut ils
ont eu des soucis c'était très très
sympathique en tout cas comme expérience
c'est la première fois que je la faisais
way et c'est vrai de rencontrer les gens
les gens avaient l'air avait l'air
content c'est ça fait plaisir c'est pas
si souvent qu'on est en contact comme ça
avec avec tout le monde avec les joueurs
les faits qui viennent jouer ce
championnat de france dans les autres
tournois les accompagnateurs et c'est
aimer ça fatigue de par contre parce que
là du coup tu es ouest n'ont pas fait
cet effort c'est vrai que j'ai hésité
avant d'accepter cette simultané ce que
l'on sait c'est vrai que c'est toujours
n'y a pas de journée de repos la fa qui
mais bon bah finalement je suis pas sûr
que ça m'a desservi tout à peut-être
eux-mêmes donné du moral finalement pas
ce que l'on fait et ça m'a donné le
rythme pour limiter après je sais pas et
alors un dernier mot sur ce sur le
tournoi perd on parlera aussi après
peut-être d'autres de l'avenir parce
qu'avec un nouveau titre de champion de
france et déjà il ya peut-être d'autres
choses que tu ai envie de faire derrière
mais évidemment dans ce titre de
champion s'est décidée au départage 1
vous dont nous et y est finalement après
un nul face à anne meara et là nul de
natacha benmesbah face à sylvie colas
bouzid et 3es ex-aequo dont natacha un
mirage toi il a fallu départager dans un
mini tournoi de blitz ses seins 3 + 2
une cadence très rapide
ouais c'est la première année que c'est
ça les départage avant c'était des
parties semi-rapides alors c'était dû en
fait c'est départir ap semi-rapide
normalement c'est parce que vous étiez 3
il sent que le règlement même
en k2 deux joueurs ça a changé et
c'était des beats n'aurait fait que ce
soit des beats après donc
donc c'est au rex et 3 plus de ça va
très très vite c'est un petit peu
aléatoires
je crois que le plus important c'est de
garder ses nerfs
bon j'ai réussi j'ai réussi à le faire
sur ces sur cd partage et je l'avais
joué d'aidé partagent déjà il ya
quelques temps un petit moment quelques
années comme sylvia colas que j'avais
perdu c'était j'avais pas du tout réussi
à maîtriser mon stress est là là
peut-être rien voilà sa carrière ça m'a
aidé les goupilles et s'est bien passé
ouais donc une magnifique cinquième
victoire alors ça te fait c'est les
années de titres c'était en 2003 ouais
2003 2008 2009 et 2011 et donc 2016 sur
sa selle clé reste pas mal
5 alors en terme de record aussi en
terme de palmarès je m'intéresse aussi à
l'histoire au palmarès mais tu rejoins
christine flir oui
minimes camille abily nif dans qui
avaient gagné beaucoup de championnats
et 70 un peu elle qui avait relancé ce
championnat de france féminin et tu es
juste à la une victoire du record absolu
de almira qui étaient là aussi cette
année et qui y est pas passé loin
d'ailleurs puisqu'elle était partagée
c'est bien si c'est très tendu superbe
victoire alors donc cette année que tu
vas tu va rejouer du grand tant que
champion de france tu veux faire le
championnat de france rapide tu va
peut-être jouer aussi en club tu vas tu
vas faire des tours - main c'est vrai
qu'à là bas j'avais décidé de ralentir
un petit peu parce que j'étais un petit
peu dans une mauvaise passe
elo a beaucoup beaucoup baissé ces
dernières années et c'est vrai que là ça
fait quand même beaucoup de bien au
moral d'avoir d'avoir gagné ce tournoi
je m'étais beaucoup préparé pour ce
championnat
et ouais ça me motive donc oui je vais
jouer par équipes en france main sur
appui en allemagne avec mon club de chf
l'ebit cheval et en angleterre avec le
club de guildford donc voilà après au
niveau au niveau des tournois où il ya
les olympiades qui sont ils sont très
bientôt
oui c'est pourtant sa de france c'est ça
la limmat scornet championnat france la
cote chez les belles équipes mais c'est
pas mal quand le champion de france dans
l'équipe 2 féminine pour pour coacher
l'équipe féminine qui vous entraîne kivu
qui sélectionneront si tout simplement
c'est vous qui c'est lui encore qui
sélectionne alors je sais pas ce qui va
garder ce poste maintenant qu'il est
chaud comme france il pourrait aussi se
dire je démissionne pas ce que je vais
faire des en tournant mais papa avant
les olympiades je pense que c'est là il
a une morale français ce même c'est bien
il va nous donner son énergie positive
voilà force et tourne assez importants
sur ok mais voilà super merci beaucoup à
ce qu'il y ait deux à voir merci et bah
j'ai envie de remercier toutes les
personnes qui m'ont soutenue pendant ce
tournoi j'ai reçu plein de messages et
voilà ça m'a beaucoup aidée aussi
pour affronter havas et ses beats de
départage décisif et et voilà merci
merci voilà merci à tout le monde
d'avoir suivi aussi bien sur des modèles
tous ces champions qui sont passés sur
le studio et avec l'émission on a
beaucoup de plaisir à commenter leur
parti ou à faire le bilan du tournant
ici comme avec sophie donc qui était
déjà passé il ya déjà qu'on maintienne
partie vous pouvez voir et qu'il a nous
a donné des supers impressions juste h
aux aguets de recevoir son titre de
champion des champions de france
officielle il ya cinq minutes des supers
donc merci à tous et donc je vous donne
rendez-vous de lors de prochaines
aventures sur diagonale tv au revoir à
va